typical midwest or nick brings in a
food challenge
i feel like this is dangerous i don't
have to go to the hospital dog
they just have to eat it right i i i
want to play
and anybody let's do teams it'll just be
it'll just be
all six of us there's only one person
out of all six of us will have to do it
whoever breaks the ice
on the don't break the ice thing has to
eat it yeah okay
i would die dude uh you like spicy
that's no chin we've seen you grill
spicy food on here
yeah let him know what are you really we
saw you drink sake and guzzle spicy [ __ ]
i feel that tits yeah dude we saw you
trying to make a slide
dog yeah trying to let that white girl
yeah about any of that [ __ ]
if you had shots in here i'll do it in
the prom try
he said he said he'd do shots it's
different a lot of
businessmen asians i'll say it take
drink a lot and take their life
yes yeah yeah okay so this is an
extremely hot yeah they do
chin is a rare you don't see a lot of
guys like chen no five years from now
chin a couple drinks
i just fall off building i just bought a
gun too yeah yeah
what they play that russian roulette and
[ __ ] bro they play japanese
chinese roulette every chamber is full
of a bullet
every chamber they flip a coin so what
how so
we gonna everybody's in on this uh yeah
i think
everybody in everybody willing to eat
this chip if they lose yeah [ __ ] it
all right she's doing it for the culture
corner
you're not in i can't handle spicy
i can't either bummer all right next for
the control room
you're just going to you're just doing
theo yeah there you go
if chappelle joins if chappelle joins
will you if chappelle joins then
everyone's in then of course i'll have
to come on
well listen up chappelle be honest with
us okay
you've obviously had a storied career
your father's been in prison you've got
right about grab
seven families you've been to school you
haven't been to school
black not black backflips yeah backflips
front flips oasis
yeah oasis um wonderwall m.i.a
you know hot topic yeah yeah uh
also now what we need to know is can you
eat this chip
i bet derrick would do it
derek would do it dude we could easily
have derek back in here
junior high trying to pressure me
don't casually try to drop like you
attended junior high
okay fine don't [ __ ] do it
yes yes peer pressure okay so
uh we'll just it will gen randomly
okay uh pick who goes first so it's even
cat will be one chappelle two
three four four five that's first
brendon six no and then we'll generate
randomly generate
forced death in korean just so you know
six brendan's first
that's a good spot now it's random and
you just you
after you hit one you have to tap that
one out
and multiple is fine you just can't no
it's like jenga
similar yes i did not have a jingle
board available now it's cat's turn yeah
the steaks are these things are [ __ ]
hot so what is it then the first person
have to eat the chip
yeah wait why do you gotta do this i
don't give a [ __ ] that's a rule man
whoever loses whoever makes the penguin
may fall out
fall through the ice oh okay has to eat
the chicken i go up and do it now mm-hmm
that packy to take back this is waiting
in your fate
yeah you got to be a uh adventure man
dude
that's how you break the ice gang yeah
damn all right nick
do it for the krusty bunks chapel the
reaper
the reaper i do before do i'm doing it
for uh high school shout out to high
school
that's what i'm doing it for damn you
know the shit's legit one says make sure
you wash your hands after eating do not
eat if you're pregnant keep out of reach
of children
dude you could pregnant women could
handle a hot shot
if they have a baby inside
yeah you can hit that easy one yeah you
can hit that hit the easy one
go ahead i set a trap for him
no you can do that not my first rodeo
this is yeah
this is your fate man mansion if you
don't hit that damn square
or another what is that an octagon or a
square
theo's up theo's up yeah brendan what
are you doing
damn i'm going versus trump no
absolute maniacs y'all
you can use both ends hit the other use
the other end
use the other end of the hammer dog that
big daddy what he picked
no stuck so i moved on
what the hell fine by me
i'm about to just eat this chip dawg
don't dog somebody about to [ __ ] [ __ ]
their pants i think
oh [ __ ] oh
nick's on the block huh
i'm so nervous who has to eat this bad
mother man
i i feel like i'm [ __ ] brendan watch
your language dude damn it ooh
wow that one touch they call me one
touch
one touch nick otn they call him one
touch nick
big dog do you want to read the back no
i don't
chin looking beautiful out here today
guys man give him a cologne or something
there we go
if you drop the hammer and it falls
after that you lose yeah yeah
who's that now chance did that go
out here [ __ ] looking beautiful dog
real dimey oh my
you got it no but that's not the one he
was hitting
this one
that's that walker bueller baby saving
the game son
let's go damn good luck brendan let's go
dude oh my god
they can't handle it they can't handle
the smoke baby
oh god damn you got to get that uh
they can't handle that smoke yeah tell
us how that chip is
yep hey what is it does he get a drink
afterwards or something to help him out
a drink right chip picky picky i don't
have a chip
i feel like brandon lost him sorry dude
[Laughter]
watch the language man god damn it shin
is 50. i am getting there chin is so
crunk
watch no because you kept taunting us
with like you guys
know what people was at stake
dude good luck i i actually want you to
do
say or say dang it
how about says warning hurts like hell
oh that only works
that's just trickery anyone want to do
it with me i want one i'll do it with
you
yeah you want one too yeah i just want
to chip
friends i respect that how many of us
have them
friends
yeah everybody's having one team work
yeah makes the dream work here's how
it's everybody's having one or they're
fired
so welcome to spotify
are you really doing this are you yeah
careful also touching the chip
don't touch your eyes yeah what i got
kids man
wait i gotta puke yeah i do but yeah one
of those kids is fine as [ __ ]
too i'll be honest bro oh yeah yeah that
little picky boy
your comments on yes shawty die me son
what are you looking spicy this is one
chip yup just one
are we just eating a pizza taking a bite
look man the whole trip
dude i know you were you know you grew
up in fear like i did dawg but we're
gonna be fine
this one chip you can handle it
chappelle
this is just like a really the craziest
back chip oh mine already broke
this could be the worst episode after
this this could be why did we start off
with this
hold on he's at the same time oh why is
it black i thought it would be red
look i'll tell you straight up man i'm
not trying to be racial but this thing
but i am but this thing bringing that
dark heat you don't have to eat the
whole thing right
no it's one chip it's like the last dab
if you want to be a big
classic yeah all right i'll do that i
can be that
yeah you got to finish no the rule is i
think we eat the whole chip yeah
we can't go half chipping out here no
one's eating the whole chip
dude it's bueller's day on bro we got
these walkers jerseys
that's a real fear walker
[ __ ] win tonight dog it doesn't even
smell good he's sure better smells like
wet dog and bologna
huh so it's like wet dog and bologna is
what it's well hello nick ate his first
the whole thing holding
oh i'm so scared no no we have milk on
the way via postmates
what postman did you eat it
how y'all doing i haven't taken a bite
yet
i'm
that powder on it is what had me feeling
risky how are you doing nick yes a
powder
i'm scared it's fine right now but i can
stop it's
coming up fast right now chin space get
red
oh yeah it's gonna get soaked oh my god
i'm worried about my insides oh i got
the hiccups oh [ __ ] here's it
oh [ __ ] oh
oh [ __ ] oh did you eat it
chevelle yeah ah damn outside my
tongue's on fire dog
i'm scared i'm crying i'm still
probably because he's i don't know he's
just a [ __ ] he was crying about it but
i'm finna try it out
let's see so as y'all can see
i ain't bullshitting man
did they say water makes it worse they
said water makes it work
no did they no why the my corner of my
mouth is ah
deal you cry pretty
what bro
calm down it's in my nose now don't
touch your face man not goddamn it
here's us what's gonna happen to us
where's the milk yeah where's the milk
bro
yeah i'm lactose intolerant too oh my
gosh
oh guys it's not a [ __ ] drug
i'll take it quickly
it's been in a car yeah oh
i got a little in my belly right now
open it up brenden my god
it's burning my my belly
oh that milk is warm
cat you're awfully quiet yep that's good
the cat over here is just chilling
cat's sweating a little bit i feel like
every time i talk in birds
all right it's uh time for some debate
clubs
[Music]
here's this guy he's got something to
say
do everything dude [ __ ] this guy bro i
need a water
[ __ ] this guy dude [ __ ] give me water
what a debate club some uh
relationship questions for you put my
job the first week of march to go
freelance
pandemic shut me down bro quiet
california
connecticut she's taking care of me here
when i'm looking for jobs
bro we can't even [ __ ] think
and he has this mask on it can't read
this that's not gonna help
let me get that gatorade do you not want
it
what do you think
are we supposed to eat more food i don't
know what to do
give me something i need to eat more
chips yeah
i'll grab some more food thank you bro
it's starting to die out for me yeah
sure
oh that damn it's carbohydrates so i
don't want carbs
it's zero sugar okay i'll get it
still on diet huh
thank you sir thank you dr pepper
my [ __ ] that lips the dumbest thing
i've ever done
theo took a big bite all right
i feel like we're too old for this my
stomach
hurts
[Laughter]
real pretty hold on bruh
does it creep up again i don't need to
calm down bro
y'all seem gay
when they eat spicy stuff that you're
real good don't be one of them spice
guys
cheers to autism we just rearranged our
chromosomes is that what this is for
autism
no that those were your last lines when
you did hot ones
oh is anyone else's like intestines do
you know how it was
what'd you say is anyone's like bottom
intestines burning yeah my stomach's
burning
my mouth died down [ __ ] is powerful
i'm straight i was hot i'm straight now
i'm good how you doing theo
i'm good was that hotter than
which is hotter i'll tell you what i'm
getting kind of aggressive this chip was
hotter
really you know this [ __ ] just feels
like okay it's remodeling me bro
actually
you know it feels like a nose no one of
them
what's still saying one of them what
i don't know leave me alone
you're saying gay stuff chappelle i
gotta [ __ ]
oh thank you man with a hat on too damn
bro
oh my god they didn't put a lot of spice
on the wings
that's the difference this chip had more
spice on it yeah
one of the spices there was spicy
nine of them were not whoo
y'all did the big bites bro i was like
man [ __ ] this did you not eat the whole
chip oh yeah
and you're acting like this bro it's
still spicy you're a [ __ ]
i'll take it you [ __ ] i'll take it you
pretty when you cry too
hold on hold on pam one's enough doug
yeah your dad was one imprisoned dog
using these prison lyrics all you have
for that son [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm on my third stevia mm-hmm
oh would we do that for autism nick
yeah what was that was that for charity
yeah
i think nick said he had an extra
chromosome or something
nick nick coming 30 minutes late with
milk
that milk was warmed up dude that milk
made me feel more sick than
[ __ ] i was ashamed of myself me too yeah
who [ __ ] drinking milk it was
disgusting oh you don't drink
homo bro i drink half the milk or
yes homo all homo yeah and that means
homogenized as well dammit it's ultra
pasteurized bro i feel bad
yeah what'd they do to them that's a lot
milk's disgusting
no [ __ ] oh and i'm like just no i don't
even want this man why are we living
like this dude
why did nick do this to him this is what
it's like in some countries brendan
india they have spices eyes burn your
face burns
huh how's your mouth my the top of my
tongue is is actually
reheated now that's like it goes in and
out like the sides of my tongue
yeah what the hell sides sizes i think i
should have swallowed it faster
you should probably didn't even eat it
dog yeah don't try jumping on this tray
yeah dude
you have your whole chip cat yep wow
the whole chip i'm pretty good with
spice
but women handle things better than men
yeah get down yeah you bunch of
different
chickens out of here dog nope yeah i
don't i don't drink that i don't [ __ ]
brother that makes your bones
a stronger ice cream would be so good
right now vanilla ice cream ice cream
oh yeah slurpee right now it sounds like
i'm looking for anything excuse me
slurpee probably yeah you didn't eat the
whole whole [ __ ] chip dog
dude this is no time to be fat dude
you eat the whole chip because you try
and put the bottle nick you eat the
whole chip
leo did you eat the whole chip yeah we
all hate that
that was the agreement it's one [ __ ]
chip son
i got high blood pressure so do i yeah
but
does that do anything to it i want to
find out i don't know
no man it's weird i just my stomach
feels like it's churning
and my tongue is getting hot again yeah
it feels like someone stabbed me in the
stomach
okay i'm almost back i'm bad i'm cool
so who let's cat handled it the best
easily man
chappelle didn't qualify you
disqualified she also got a whole ass
chip over there dude how much you got
left hold that up hold
and away from your body off to the side
look at that put it by the white wall
just so we can see it
man around oh yeah yeah
yeah so we can yeah so so we can see the
chip
there we go your little way your little
big ass ate a freaking little
baby body dog nibble then start acting
like you ate the whole thing like
yeah and he's saying you beautiful dawg
beautiful god damn we should sting a
shirt
yeah yeah you didn't say anything about
churchill
like that gay dude at the sleepover
trying to get you all drunk wait so
everybody ate the whole chip
yeah yeah man everybody gangsters do it
yeah you do it the rest of the show is
gonna
be if you do it swallow it faster
because it's
it's burning the top of my tongue right
now okay all right
i'm shocked bro do what you're doing oh
representing the black community poorly
today bro sorry i will say that
i got to do it huh it's your people
though hey man blm dawg it's your help
oh my god
damn oh you're taking too long to
swallow it
will you take too long just swallow it
don't spit it out [ __ ] up
you got to stay with me oh you took too
long you swallowed okay
cattle nurture cattle cat will help you
no why did you guys make sure
that he didn't you didn't eat it oh no
no i'll come back he's
[Applause]
and look there ain't a man in there
that's for sure okay
you beautiful when you cry dawg we gotta
give the hell and then he kept saying it
yeah give him a polygraph
your lips get all pouty when you get eat
spicy stuff yeah
what like damn you look beautiful when
you he's like oh that shirt goes with
your tears i'm like what
bro we need to give him a dang uh test
man
that gay test i think we just did he ran
out the room
that chip's really a gay test if it
burns you inside
you ain't christian i mean he was coming
in did he seem a little gay to you shin
i saw a real fear the first time i
actually saw him really but i'm not
asking him
now i'm not saying did he seem scared i
said did he see him i say it a little
bit
maybe a little bit you know what i'm
saying you guys are [ __ ] up though
this is where you [ __ ] up
he's like i can't eat the whole thing i
gotta chew it i'm like yeah but do it
fast but he didn't listen
and so he's really he i know that thing
up like
i'm telling him he's [ __ ] his mouth i
told him i told him to see the way he
chewed it
oh dude he's just like coated his tongue
yeah i'm good i'm good i'm so you think
i'm back
let's get into the episode yeah someone
stabbed me in the stomach but i'm fine
my mouth's fine yeah don't do that again
nick
this guy sounds like a deadbeat i've
seen people say oh do hot ones do hot
ones we did that ones
yeah that was beyond hot that was hotter
man
the only thing that was more spice that
was the thing there was more spice in
that
hot one they don't do that much spice
bro i'm glad that brendan lost
because i feel like if it would have
been like one of the crew
it would they would just split down on
their own you know like
i think everybody doing it together yeah
that was fun that's the way to do it
where the [ __ ] you [ __ ] looks more
asian after you did it
your eyes are no i swear it's more
squinty i swallow and bloat
very fast wow you're like one of those
fish
i am like blowfish when i eat ramen boom
my face i can't even see
yeah the spicy ramen sodium
my god bro dude is he okay
he's not okay right he ate too much
he's fine i'm a little worried about
spell now me too he kind of gave me a
headache guys
you guys have no faith in different uh
cultures then
he's fine he doesn't look like hell is a
black man okay
he his people have been through tons of
[ __ ] he can handle one
spicy chip it didn't look like you guys
like i don't know it's the way he chewed
it though that's going to give him
the way he chewed it have you seen
[ __ ] amazon dude
and that's the penalty for being a
coward yeah
yeah bro that's a penalty for being
coward and also getting real gay after
you eat that chip
bro he kept commenting on theo's cheers
he took a body
bite of it hold on he took a nibble of
it and then goes
you look so tense and i'm like what yeah
they kept going
y'all two should relax more why doesn't
cat get out of here yeah i wonder if
there's any restaurants that are open at
night
for us i'm like what
what are you talking about i'm worried
about us we should all stay over my
place
yeah yeah yeah what did he oh he's like
what if the power
keeps going out i'm like what it hasn't
gone out
you guys want to see
[Laughter]
god you [ __ ] care bear get it
together dude
chapelle should be the darkest care bear
that's his new nickname
the darkest dark beer because he is
leave him out there this is a learning
time
this is a learning time this is a good
oh when what no i have nothing
he's okay he's able to speak he's just
gargling milk
oh my gosh bring up somebody that was in
a fire
victim bring up someone that was in an
actual fire and let me see or
google burn victim or black history i'm
just saying there are people that have
really really suffered
you know what's the famous picture of
the vietnamese woman burning in the fire
remember at the war
oh no she's protesting no no that's the
there's a monk that put himself on fire
he didn't move at all
that's real dawg that was a postmate no
he was doing the same competition weird
there we go same competition over rage
against machine albums yeah he's doing
the same competition there we go
we brought him back but yeah yeah we
brought him back with the cover
how's your mouth though chappelle i
didn't owe it quick enough i know
i don't know i chewed it like that bro
you did not need to do all that
but at least you went through something
yeah i went through something i
appreciate y'all pushing me do you feel
better to do something that
you know you put you put me out of my
comfort zone and you really pushed me
and that was uh yeah that was uh i just
thank you guys
how's your insights he's gonna be fine
what do you mean
he's inside he's fine dude i'm good
inside right mine's
i think this is the perfect the perfect
time to
thank you don't let him say it again
he's your friend uh
so we when we had little browsing okay
everybody said enough kind of gay stuff
on this episode
and i'm not pointing names or fingers at
anybody
okay but i feel like we've hit kind of a
the gay the gay meters here
chappelle nietzsche he was in a movie
crying and [ __ ] i cried with you
that's pretty good
no more chips for you no
no more snacks for you man at least now
we know why he didn't want to eat spicy
foods
that makes him gay i don't blame him
yeah dude yeah
[Music]